supposed to be Nick next but he seems to
have gone walkabout crazy good eye if
you're wondering why I've decided to
hide out in the jungle it's actually
rather simple I've gone back to the
outback to escape from the world that's
gone bonkers insane crazy nuttier than a
pistachio harvest in the space of a few
days students at Somerville College
Oxford the College Margaret Thatcher
attended voted to ban the Union flag
from being thrown on the Queen's
birthday because it's quotes a symbol of
colonialism animal rights campaigners
after the residents of the sleepy Dorset
village of rule to change its name to
vegan wool as it's kinder to sheep a
potato crisp company has pulled the plug
on its Welsh rarebit flavour snack as a
picture of a miner on the packet
offended some Welsh people and Chinese
social media banned an advert for dr.
Edgar Bona
because it showed a Chinese girl trying
to eat spaghetti and pizza with
chopsticks you with me now taking a
fence where there is none or virtue
signalling has become a global obsession
what happens when something really
offensive happens we're losing all sense
of perspective so join me and declare
I'm not a celebrity but get me out of
here
[Laughter]
yes you know I love you standing there
in the jungle saying how offended you
are that people are getting offended
it's a brilliant and rich irony listen
okay let's take the wool thing yeah the
wolf thing
it's pizza has everyone around this
table heard of pizzas know better I
think you've been out with it Peter the
reason that we've all heard of pizza is
because they are notorious the gimmicks
to grab our attention Naomi Campbell
wearing a Dem just gave them attention
you have just helped their marketing
strategy that saccs a key why they did
this they didn't seriously expect a
village and it's not even named wool
after sheep's wool it's named wool after
something else you think they might
Google bad pet I wouldn't know but what
they all know that there are people who
were worried about the humanity of the
wool industry which I personally wasn't
that aware of before so it's very
effective I don't get too stuck into the
wall the broader point is if we allow
ourselves to take offense over a packet
of crisps an advert for a fashion
company or the name of a town Cameron
let's bring you in when something true
did just for the purpose of debate if I
was to go and urinate on a war memorial
or something like that when something is
truly genuinely if where we left to go
that is the reality I do so another
example that you mentioned was at
Somerville College a toxin yes now this
is the College of Margaret Thatcher
attended Indira Gandhi attend I've had
an association with that College and you
know there that there were members of
the student there college students union
who said that the Union Jack should not
be flown at the college because it's a
symbol of colonialism yeah I mean that
is ridiculous and the college said we
fly the Union Jack four times a year on
special occasions or a member of the
royal family visits a college and we
will continue to fly the Union Jack the
minefield now I think there are
professional listeners who wants us to
say the slightest masseur so how do we
how do we start to sieve what is really
offensive that's what I Drive agreed and
this is where I say offense is taken not
given right
usually the case that actually the
person who is offended is looking for
something to be offended by but up to
take upwards point it is a wonderful
irony that you are also taking offense
this is how we achieve progress right
it's not perfect Somerville used to be a
women's college there was a time when
women were protesting that colleges at
Oxford and other universities should be
integrated between the genders it was
regarded as a ridiculous insane argument
that would never have any traction
people lobbied for things they spark
debate that is part of being a democracy
the market thanks my dear and actually
free speech people who are the quick to
shut down people like me are the first
to get offended okay okay let's look at
how this offends this kind of political
correctness of offense started have
started back in the 60s and 70s as a
much-needed response to racism and
sexism and and and had it just stuck to
that to protecting and but these ricky
gervais some did it oh but he said I see
offense as the collateral damage of free
speech which is actually that you can't
modify what you think or what you feel
in case it might offend someone
somewhere and I think the main point of
all this is people like your effort
don't take into account anymore whether
people mean to offend because that's the
whole point if you mean to offend if you
don't you can't but people don't mean
they can still have careers damaged
lives ruined everything wrecked because
they said something that you have
decided is wrong all that Albertsons
company starts apologizing for a
caricature on the cover of what had on
that crisp Agatha should have been done
on the basis it was too long ago you
would have been other aspect to all this
is with humor and I think that this
country has always had the most
wonderful reputation of being able to
laugh at ourselves yeah and not to take
it seriously but as good humor yes and
then where do you draw the line when
there's a complete lack of any humor at
all because you have scared of offending
about power you know and the groups the
groups that you now think are ridiculous
for trying to protect themselves from
offensive language or things that they
feel are dimensional groups that have to
understand what it's like to experience
oppression I'm not just talking about
rape I'm talking about as well oh no my
god let's take a look at Hackett for
those those who have not seen the pack
imagined afters for those who haven't
seen the video the dolce gabbana video
which is a bit banned by Chinese social
media let's take a look at this she
tries to embarrass Italian dishes are
you offended I'm not Chinese and I don't
know what it's like Syrians and
prejudiced attitudes towards being
Chinese and I'm filtering about it did
take this seriously and this is what
they said we are very sorry for any
distress caused by these honourable
house comments and direct messages we
have nothing but respect for China and
the people of China you know what this
is about having open enough mind to
understand there are people who've had
an experience that is different to yours
who experienced the course of this
program we've had a crisp packet
apologizing with a fashion brand
apologizing we've had a college
apologizing I mean it in the problem
with this of course it's not just comedy
but also actually thought police in in
the sense that what with a skier bebés
case for blasphemy there are real-life
consequences to how far we take this
people are being killed because they're
being deemed heretical or blasphemous
for offending the sentiments of a group
and the key point here with this RF
where is that actually people don't done
all think that think the same so there
is no what does a Welsh person feel Mike
there is no what is a Chinese person
feel like that though
no offense really but we must move on
because that's almost it but before we
go there's just time for this now we on
the pledge are all about straight
talking and we salute those who say it
like it is
this week unfortunately we lost someone
who did that for almost a century
Baroness Trumpington was a land girl a
wartime code breaker at Bletchley Park a
counselor and a mayor she worked for two
prime ministers and served in the House
of Lords which she retired from last
year but above all she was a woman with
a sharp wit and a great sense of humor
and she was happy to break the rules who
starts to look pretty old as well as my
noble friend the Baroness reminded me I
believe claiming to be one Li the only
survivor I think in this house those who
gave great service I would like to know
why at the age of 90 I've had to sign a
piece of paper in order to be on this
show to say I wasn't pregnant he's a
member of the cabinet we heard of him it
was that dodge so this week we're
remembering Baroness Trumpington the
ultimate straight talker who sadly
passed away at the age of 96 Karen one
of your party I count myself lucky to
have known Baroness Trumpington and two
quick stories I congratulated Gordon
Brown I was the first person in
Parliament to speak after he became
prime minister and as I walked out of
the chamber
she dict me off how dare you congratu
Labor Prime Minister and then after that
once I was sitting opposite her at lunch
to only the two of us at the table and I
politely offered her some water water
never touched the stuff and she had a
large glass of wine in front
she was formidable a great lady a unique
talent and farewell from us that's all
for this week and thank you for watching
[Music]